hello everyone and welcome back to the
skilling open we are continuing with the
match hikaru nakamura versus maksim
vashiya lagrav
uh and as you know mvl won their uh
first match yesterday and
now well uh the day before yesterday and
now uh nakamura has the win to get back
into the match and then
force a blitz playoff so it was a really
crazy day yesterday and they played so
many interesting games i couldn't decide
which one to show you
so i'm just gonna briefly show you
positions from uh game one and game
three and then we're gonna go to the
game that i'm actually going to show
so this is uh the first game where
nakamura had the white pieces
and uh well this is the basically final
position here nakamura played bishop to
d3
and the maxim vashila grav resigned as
well there is nothing more to be done
here the
the rook is trapped you can easily trap
the rook uh you can just push the pass
at this
past h pawn to victory and black black
doesn't really have a
good move or or any move for that matter
to continue this uh this game
so uh here maxine vashir lagrav resigned
the game
and also i would like to show you this
position this is from the second game of
the rapids where nakamura also had the
white pieces the other two games
uh of the rapids where uh nvl had the
white piece descended in a draw so
this is the position i wanted to show
you uh a lot of moves are possible here
uh rook the c1 was played uh
was played by hikaru uh and here uh mvl
played the d5 sorry about that
uh he attacked the knight on e4 and now
nakamura has to decide what to do with
the knight to go to g5 to go to c5 or
whatnot and also
uh the b6 pawn is is kind of hanging so
you have to also keep that in mind
but nakamura played rook to c7 and he
sacrificed
the exchange here so now now you cannot
capture the pawn because just queen
captures on f7 with check followed by
queen h7 checkmate
so uh mvl accepted the rook and now we
have queen to d8 with
check king to g7 and now b captures on
c7
and uh it was again in this position
that mvl resigned the game
whatever you do upon the c8 is queen on
the next move and there's nothing you
can do about this
so nakamura easily won uh won their
second match and now
uh he was able to force for the playoffs
so in the playoffs we have two blitz
games
five plus three and then if that also
ends in a draw then we go into
armageddon so this is game
uh uh two of the blitz that we're going
to show here
uh game one was won by mvl which was so
it's a complete roller coaster first uh
nakamura wins two games of the rapids he
gets back into the match and then
uh mvl wins the first game of the blitz
so now he only needs a draw from this
one
uh to get to you know clinch the match
and uh
i'll go into the semi-finals uh but uh
you know anything can still happen so
nakamura needs a win here
and let's see what happens uh he has the
white pieces and nakamura opens with d4
so in the uh uh previous two games with
the white pieces nakamura played e4 and
he won
uh against maximes and niger which is uh
uh you don't it doesn't get any better
than that
maksim is the absolute best player of
the of the night of sicilian in the
world and
nakamura just crushed in both games i
was really wild
so here nakamura needs a win he needs
something different uh he probably
thinks that maksim can
also uh well just uh that he knows
a lot more variation that that can
easily you know
a bit more it is going to be a bit more
easier to force a draw
uh with the knight over so he goes for
d4 as he really needs a win here
knight f6 and bishop to g5 he goes for
the trombovsky attack
uh we have d5 and e3 now we have c5
challenging the center and c3 uh the
bishop is out of the cage and now a very
solid setup by nakamura
and the queen to b6 putting pressure on
the b2 pawn here
uh queen to b3 is is a very common move
just offering a queen trade
but nakamura needs a win and he's not
interested in trading queen so he plays
queen to c1
guards the b2 pawn that way
and now bishop to f5 so what do we have
here
knight to d2 by nakamura and the knight
b to d7 so just both players continue
developing knight g to f3
and now e6 preparing to develop the dark
square bishop as well
knight to h4 attacking the bishop here
and here there is one move in the
database
uh that was played 20 years ago where
bishop the g6 was played but here we
have bishop to e4
and it is as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens uh nakamura
continues with a4
and we have a6 we have bishop to e2
just continuing development and now h6
now saying you have to capture my knight
here
because if you go back just g5 and i win
uh win one of your pieces so after h6
nakamura has to trade bishop captures
knight captures and now
knight captures an e4 we have d captures
on e4
and here again uh there is some danger
that the g5 will trap the knight and
also you're not uh
the f3 square is covered so g3 making
room for the knight on g2
bishop to e7 by mvl and now nakamura
finally castles we have castles by nvl
and queen to c2 uh with rook
8 to c8 and both players now mobilize
their rooks rook after d1
rook after d8 and rook 8 to c1 and we
can say that now
both sides have finished development of
their of their
heavy pieces and now probably nakamura
will try and shift the knight back into
the game with
moves like this so captures here you
cannot capture with the c
pawn as the queen would be hanging so e
captures on d4 and now
knight to d5 an excellent square for the
knight and you don't really care about
any c4 ideas because you you can never
capture as long as the queen is on c2
so knights to g2 nakamura starts
bringing the knight back into the game
and now
f5 strengthening the position here is
somewhat weakening the e6 pawn but the
white pieces are nowhere near
uh the e6 pawn and here nakamura goes
queen back to b1
uh he wants to start pushing on the
queen side but also maybe you can
uh use this diagonal in some of your
some of your tactics
we have bishop to g5 now uh maxime
attacks the rook on c1
and rook to c2 for those of you who are
maybe new to chess as a lot of people
are new to chess nowadays
uh if you block the bishop with f4
there's always e captures on f3 alpha
song
and if you're a beginner it's easy to
miss stuff like that
so here rook to c2 uh just getting the
rook out of harm's way and now comes
queen to b3
uh seemingly attacking the a4 pawn uh
so uh nakamura defends it but that
wasn't the actual threat after queen to
b3 was played
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the strongest continuation for
mvl
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on winning the
exchange and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
knight to b4 and now you can see the
problem the rook is under attack you
cannot move it anywhere because the
bishop controls this diagonal and of
course if you capture just rook captures
and that's it uh there's not much you
can do here
you're gonna stop gobbling up the entire
queen side and there's
no move you can play here if you move
the bishop let's say bishop to f1
you can capture here again just pick up
everything everything is falling
and it's just a completely winning
position for for black
so after night before nakamura was like
how how could i have missed this this is
uh you know
i i really need a win to get back into
the into the match
so he gave up the exchange rook back to
c1 and
mvl grabs it bishop captures rook
captures and now
knight back to d5 and here nakamura has
a problem
uh he's uh well he's just down the
exchange and it's not going to be
an easy game for him but he will try
there's
not much more you can do so f3 he starts
by attacking the e4 pawn
and envel trades this as it is a double
pawn so captures captures and now
queen back to b5 going after the a5 pawn
but now what we said that the e6 pawn
was a little bit weak with this trait
here
nakamura was able to make a target of it
so rook to e1
attacking the e6 pawn which is an
important pawn uh the
defending a lot of things here rook to
e8 defending and now
queen to a2 with some some tactics
uh you know maybe possibly in the future
uh but for the moment regarding the a5
pawn we have king the h8 getting the
king out of this diagonal
and now bishop to h5 and here you can
see that
it's not going to be all that easy king
to h8 maybe wasn't
the the most precise move because now
nakamura is planning uh
knight to h4 to g6 so the rook is under
attack uh mbl moves it and now
knight stage four threatening knight to
g6 uh to win the rook on e7
so came to h7 not allowing any any such
checks but now uh
knight to g6 also a possibility here was
bishop to g6
that can win material and i don't think
nakamura missed this i
i think he just didn't uh calculate
if it would be enough to to play for a
win after all is said and done because
after king h8
you can capture on f5 and then after he
captures on f5 uh the point is
knight the g6 check is available again
because the king moved
and then after king moves captures
captures and captures and now we have
this position
uh where nakamura would be up upon and
his position is a bit more active but
would would it be enough for a win it's
uh it's hard to say and of course for a
blitz game
uh you know you don't have all that much
time to calculate everything so he
keeps the tension on the board knights
the g6 now puts pressure on the rook
and rook e to c7 uh we have knight to e5
now by nakamura
also rook captures an e6 is possible uh
none of the none of the commentators
knew why nakamura
uh didn't go for the pawn uh but okay he
tried knight to e5 first and now king
back to g8 not allowing any checks
knight back to g6 and king to h7 uh with
uh
as it's a blitz game both players are
low on time uh
maximum shareholder would be very happy
with the repetition of moves in the draw
here
but he repeats uh one move one move too
much
because going back with the queen you
need to guard this pawn this is what you
have to do
he continued just repeating moose king
to h7 maybe he thought
nakamura was interested in a draw
although that doesn't really make any
sense
and then nakamura finally grabs the e6
pawn and now
everything becomes weak this is weak
this is weak uh
everything is just weak so here probably
why mvl allowed it is this knight to f6
move which
seems like it attacks the bishop after
the bishop moves you can pick up the
knight
the problem is bishop moves with tempo
bishop to e2 now attacks the queen and
the knight will be saved so queen d5 now
uh offering a trade of queens
and of course now nakamura very happily
except the queen trade knight captures
and now bishop the d3
as the knight is now protected you're
also threatening to pick up the f5 pawn
so rook to f7 defending and now well you
could play g4
and just bust open that diagonal this
way
we have knight to e5 first by nakamura
with rook f back to f8 and now
rook to d6 challenging the knight here
93
and now rook to d7 going after the b7
pawn so now nakamura knows that he's uh
uh he's much better here uh and he will
try and play really really fast without
playing vl mdl is still up the exchange
but
uh the the the knight and bishop are
just too active
so rook to b8 defending and now rook
back to d6 will rook beat the c8 and now
nakamura tries attacking the b for
b pawn uh from uh from the b file
rook to c7 defending now from the
seventh rank and king f2 now nakamura
starts bringing the king into the game
knight d5 will rook to d6 again pushing
the knight back
97 and now knight to d7 with some
uh with some tricks on the board if for
example maxime tries to win the
knight then knight f6 check will pick up
the rook on d8
so of course mvl doesn't fall for that
rook to f7 and now
knight to c5 uh we have knight to c6
and now b4 defending the a5 pawn that
maxine was hoping
uh to grab uh we have g6 now defending
the pawn here and
now h4 and although you could play h5
here to prevent
white from advancing the h pawn uh then
you might create uh sort of a
well sort of a a permanent outpost on g5
for
for white's knight so uh nvl continues
with knight e7
and now bishop to c4 first challenging
the rook rook the g7 and now bishop back
to b3 if you want to move this knight
you have to move this bishop first
so bishop back to b3 and now rook to c6
offering a trade here nakamura declines
he goes rook to d7
and now knights the c8 uh nvl really
wants to
trade down and here finally nakamura
does it captures captures
and now as the b7 pawn is under attack
uh nakamura just
uh attacks it one attacks the rook one
more time because if you capture right
away
then uh you also lose the c3 pawn and
you allow
uh mvl to get back into the game so here
bishop to d5
attacking the rook and now uh
unfortunately you have to move the rook
away from the c file you can just uh
keep it here forever you have to move it
but whatever you play
uh your your position will just fall
apart this will fall this will probably
fall
and it's going to be very very difficult
to defend this uh
most likely impossible but it's a blitz
game so anything could have happened
however
rook the c7 was played here and now uh i
don't even have to ask you to pause the
video because you know what nakamura
played here
it's uh very very obvious so uh since
everyone found it i'm just going to show
it to you
knight the e6 check was played and it
was in this position that hikaru
nakamura
or rather maksim vashir lagrav resigned
the game and
a great victory for hikaru nakamura that
gets him back into the match
so here he equalized then they played
one more game they played an armageddon
game where nakamura chose the black
pieces
and he was able to hold off uh maksim to
a draw
which means that nakamura is the winner
but it was a it was such a such a crazy
day yesterday and i thought
wow which game i'm gonna show i better
show you just you know little bits of
you know all of them not all of them but
some of them so i hope
you enjoy that as well i hear you resign
because after the king moves you just
pick up the rook and now it's completely
winning
uh no point in even in even trying to
you know play for some tricks here
so after knight to 86 check uh mvl
resigned and
nakamura uh you know uh proceeds to win
the
armageddon game as well will not win uh
he he won the match by drawing the
armageddon game with black
because you know if you're black in
armageddon and the game ends in a draw
then it's a victory for you you know
chess is weird like that
uh so uh once again i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
patrick capps um subramanian kurt wendla
pierrot thibault and patrick andriano
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon uh continuing
the coverage of the skilling open
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent
rest of your your day